en ce qui concerne le premier côté de l'affaire, il y a
vu les implications économiques
oui c'est de ça qu'on parle maintenant
comment nous réussissons, y compris dans
Les relations de l'Iran avec l'Eurasie
l'union économique n'est pas
permettre le commerce et en général
Coopération économique
grimacer
au contraire, elle augmente, notamment en raison de
arrêter d'utiliser le dollar de portage
centre de gravité à utiliser dans les calculs
monnaies nationales utilisation d'autres
nouveaux schémas créatifs
et l'interaction économique est tout
fonctionne et je suis convaincu que cela fonctionnera
continuer et nous chercherons tous les nouveaux
et de nouvelles formes efficaces
ignorer les effets économiques négatifs
sans effet, on sait juste déjà qu'en
conditions dans lesquelles ces instruments
sont déjà devenus monnaie courante entre les mains de nos
On ne peut pas faire confiance aux collègues occidentaux
compter sur eux comme fiables
on ne peut pas non plus compter sur les partenaires
les possibilités des pays qui suivent
fermement aux principes du droit international et
dont la fiabilité ne fait aucun doute
il y a un deuxième côté de la question il y a
en raison d'aspects juridiques internationaux
il faut augmenter
bon sens de l'entreprise
d'autres ont besoin de sites tiers sur
la condamnation de telles pratiques et
promouvoir une compréhension commune de
cela devrait être arrêté nous beaucoup
années avec vous avec l'écrasante
majorité des membres votent en
soutien à une résolution sur l'illégalité
blocus économique de Cuba, par exemple, et
il n'y a que deux trois membres de l'organisation
avec les États-Unis
ne supporte pas cette résolution maintenant
nos efforts communs alors que vous
mettez-le ce club
club de justice
affaires du monde économique
formé et il préconise catégoriquement
contre de telles pratiques par nos efforts
création d'un poste de rapporteur spécial
organisations il leurs nations sur le problème
économique unilatéral illégal
les sanctions doivent être soutenues de toutes les manières possibles
activités de cette importante institution